>> Sean: AS WE CONTINUE ON
"HANNITY," THE CLINTONS ALWAYS
SEEM TO GET A FREE PASS.
TODAY, THE FBI HAS RAIDED THE
HOME OF A WHISTLE-BLOWER AND
ACTUALLY GAVE DOCUMENTS
PERTAINING TO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION AND URANIUM ONE TO
THE GOVERNMENT WATCHDOG.
YOU WANT REAL RUSSIA COLLUSION,
THE REAL STORY WITH REAL
EVIDENCE AND THE REAL PROOF?
REMEMBER, MULTIPLE AGENCIES HAVE
APPROVED THE TRANSFER, 20% OF
U.S. MARINE, URANIUM.
AND THEY ARE SUING FOR DOCUMENTS
ABOUT THE EFFORTS BY THE OBAMA
DOJ, INTO THE FOUNDATION.
WHAT ABOUT THE FOUNDATION
SILENCE ON ALL THEIR DONATIONS
FROM THE SAUDIS AND OTHER
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS THAT WE HAVE
DOCUMENTED ON THIS PROGRAM?
HARDLY A PEEP, AND TAMMY BRUCE
IS BACK WITH US.
PUTIN'S THUGS HERE IN AMERICA,
AND THE SALE WENT THROUGH, AND
THE MONEY GOT KICKED BACK.
NOT A PEEP IN THE MEDIA.
>> THE SYSTEM IS ESTABLISHED TO
PROTECT.
AND THIS IS WHY THIS IS SUCH A
SLOPPY SYSTEM WITH THE HILLARY
CAMPAIGN.
AND SUDDENLY THANK GOODNESS,
BECAUSE OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
IN DONALD TRUMP, WHO KNOWS HOW
LONG.
GENERATION CERTAINLY, AND THE
SYSTEM IS MEANT TO DO THIS.
IT'S OF COURSE THE MUTANT KIND
OF SYSTEM THAT PROTECTS THE BAD
GUYS.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
CHANGING THAT.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE AT LEAST A
GENERATION TO MOVE US OUT OF
THIS CORRUPT KIND OF FRAMEWORK.
IT'S GOING TO FIGHT BACK, AND
THE ENTIRE MONSTER IS GEARED TO
FIGHTING BACK, AND WE ARE THE
BULWARK HERE.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE THE
ONES NOW THROUGH, THANK
GOODNESS, THE INTERNET, NEW
MEDIA, MULTIPLE MODES OF
MUNICATION AND CABLE TELEVISION
THAT MAKES THE DIFFERENCE.
SO THE COMMUNICATION FRAMEWORK
WILL BE DIFFERENT.
>> Sean: FOR EXAMPLE,
GOVERNOR.
YOU HAVE ALL THESE PEOPLE IN THE
SENATE JUDICIARY.
I BELIEVE, WHATEVER THE CHARGE
THAT THEY BELIEVED AT ALL, THEY
DIDN'T SAY A WORD ABOUT THE
CHARGES NOT 36 YEARS AGO BUT
KEITH ELLISON, EMOTIONAL AND
PHYSICAL ABUSE.
WE KNOW ALL THE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST A BILL, THEY DIDN'T SAY
A WORD ABOUT MICHAEL AVENATTI,
HE WASN'T GOING TO GIVE BRETT
KAVANAUGH DUE PROCESS OR
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE, AND
RUSSIAN COLLUSION, BUT NOT IF
IT'S HILLARY'S DOSSIER OR
URANIUM ONE AND THEY THOUGHT
RUSSIA WAS SO BAD THAT THEY
WOULD WANT TO JOIN US AND GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF IT.
>> THIS ISN'T ABOUT TRUTH,
JUSTICE OR THE AMERICAN WAY.
THIS IS ABOUT RAW POWER.
THAT'S WHY IT SHOULD BE SO VERY
TROUBLING.
I DON'T THINK YOU OR ANYONE ELSE
IN AMERICA TRULY BELIEVES THAT
BILL CLINTON GAVE A SPEECH THAT
WAS WORTH HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
IN MOSCOW, WHILE COINCIDENTALLY,
IT JUST SO HAPPENED THAT THE
URANIUM DEAL WENT THROUGH AND I
DON'T THINK HE'S INVESTIGATING
THAT WHILE HE HAS THIS
INCREDIBLE UNIT OF DEMOCRATS
THAT HE HAS ASSEMBLED DO THE
INVESTIGATION OF RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
THE REAL RUSSIA COLLUSION IS
SEEMINGLY GOING INVESTIGATING.
>> BUT WE ARE LIKE AN ISLAND
HERE.
BRINGING UP NEWS AND
INFORMATION, WITH EVIDENCE WHICH
IS SOMETHING THEY DON'T HAVE
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
AND YET, IT PENETRATES, AND IT
PENETRATES.
AND I BET ANYTHING MUELLER WILL
TRY TO USE A SLEDGEHAMMER TO TRY
TO BLUDGEON IN HIS REPORT,
DONALD TRUMP.
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT
BUT THE PRESIDENT PASSED TO HAS
TO APPOINT A PERMANENT ATTORNEY
GENERAL NOT A TEMPORARY LIKE
WHAT OCCURRED.
MAYBE IT'S TREY GOWDY, MAYBE
IT'S SEAN HANNITY.
>> Sean: I WOULDN'T GET ONE
VOTE.
>> THAT COULD BE A BAD IDEA,
THEY WOULD NEVER CONFIRM YOU.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE SOMEONE, SEAN,
WHO IS GOING TO BE RELENTLESS.
NOT IN TRYING TO BE HARSH TO THE
DEMOCRATS BUT TRYING TO BE FAIR
TO THE TRUTH.
>> LET ME ADD, BECAUSE THE
PERSON WHO IS GOING TO DO THE
BEST JOB WILL BE THE PERSON WHO
THE DEMOCRATS FREAK OUT ABOUT
THE MOST.
THIS IS WHY THE SENATE, AS IT
EXISTS NOW, EVEN WITH ROMNEY, WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THE PRESIDENT
MAKES IT CLEAR TO MITCH
McCONNELL AND EVERY OTHER
SENATOR IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
THAT THIS MATTERS.
THAT THE NEXT ATTORNEY GENERAL
MUST BE CONFIRMED.
THAT THEY CANNOT ALLOW THE
DEMOCRATS TO MUCK UP THE WATERS
AND CHANGE THE FRAMEWORK.
EVERYTHING IS AT STAKE BECAUSE A
PERSON WHO IS RIGHT FOR THAT
OFFICE AND EVERY APPOINTEE OF
THE PRESIDENT WILL UPSET PEOPLE
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE THEY